hallo erkunder ist etwas nervös gerade
mal fünf monate lernen sie deutsch jetzt
muss sie schon ihr erstes
vorstellungsgespräch in dieser sprache
führen mitarbeiter vom deutschen
uniklinikum düsseldorf sind darum extra
nach namibia gekommen
januar
nach der mine abschluss gibt es viele
das habe ich kein kunde hat an der uni
krankenpflege studiert doch im anschluss
keinen job gefunden so ging es vielen
ihrer kommilitonen
[Musik]
denn am ilias wirtschaft steckt in einer
krise der gesundheitsminister will zwar
4000 weitere pflegekräfte einstellen
doch für mehr fehle das geld
namibia ist eines der wenigen länder
afrikas das meer krankenpfleger
ausbildet als es einstellen kann
dass die arbeitslosen fachkräfte eine
weile ins ausland gehen ist für ihn eine
gute lösung
country manager dirk country music
hightech deutschland ist ein
entwickeltes land sie benutzten hightech
und haben andere lösungsansätze und
andere bedingungen
es ist gut etwas neues kennenzulernen
sie lernen etwas dann kommen sie zurück
und wenden es an
es wird viel über brain drain in
afrikanischen ländern gesprochen aber
namibia ist davon nicht betroffen des
hessen perfekt imitiert die
personalbeschaffung firma von tilman
frank hat die 16 krankenpfleger
ausgewählt und zahlt den deutschkurs der
sie für den deutschen markt fit machen
soll
mehr als 1000 pfleger aus zwölf ländern
hat frank bereits nach deutschland
geholt
wenn eine klinik die pfleger nimmt
bekommt seine firma eine prämie
deutschlands bevölkerung wird älter und
immer weniger junge menschen wollen in
der pflege arbeiten also die nachfrage
ist gigantisch also die deutsche
krankenhausgesellschaft hat von 60.000
fehlenden pflegekräften gesprochen
mit der sprache und der
berufsanerkennung
dann werden wir ihn aus der hand
gerissen
[Musik]
stehen
vorstellungsgespräche in windhuk
unterdessen vorbei das team vom
uniklinikum ist begeistert über sie
gesprochen ob gegen einzelne wir hatten
sie alle interview
und ich kann ihnen sagen dass wir vom
klinikum entschieden haben dass wir sie
alle gerne der job ist in der tasche
jetzt müssen die krankenpfleger nur noch
die sprachprüfung bestehen
dann geht es bereits im april nach
düsseldorf
[Musik]